at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start
shaking can i answer your personal
question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal endoscopy
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss welcome to another
episode of the tim ferriss show this
episode is a special episode it is a
live recording from an event hosted by
the edmund hillary fellowship the edmund
hillary fellowship otherwise known as
ehf began in 2016 as a pilot immigration
program and has matured into a
fellowship of more than 500
technologists creatives investors
entrepreneurs educators and systems
designers among many other things
committed to new zealand as a base camp
for global impact from more than 50
different nationalities including new
zealand fellows span a range of high
value sectors such as media education
cleantech venture capital and mental
health initiatives and research as we
will hear in just a few moments and
that's just to name a few ehf and its
fellows aim to make a meaningful impact
in new zealand aotearoa with projects
that often have global applications we
talk a bit about that and certainly
explore a lot more with today's guest
you can learn more about ehf at ehf.org
greetings to you all and welcome to
today's ehf live session the edmund
hillary fellowship is a collective of
entrepreneurs scientists storytellers
creatives and investor change makers who
want to make an impact globally from
aotearoa new zealand
in this session today you're going to
hear from tim ferriss he's an ehf fellow
who is an early stage technology
investor and advisor and tim will be
interviewing dr shiresh an associate
professor at auckland university and the
topic today is on mental health and
breakthrough therapeutics
there'll be plenty of time for q a with
tim and sheree during the 90 minute
session but nearer the end over to you
tom
thank you very much michelle it's
pleasure to be here and it's a pleasure
to be doing a live session i have been
looking forward to this for some time
and without further ado let me introduce
the main attraction and the guest of the
hour and that is dr suresh mutu kumara
swami i will hear forward refer to him
as suresh suresh is an associate
professor of psychopharmacology at the
university of auckland
and he completed his phd in psychology
at the university of auckland in 2005
after which he joined the newly
established cardiff university brain
research imaging center as a
postdoctoral fellow while at cardiff he
started research work with the
psychedelics and psychedelic compounds
in 2011 in collaboration with two very
well-known names professor david nutt
and dr robin carhart harris
investigating the neuroimaging
correlates of the psychedelic drugs
psilocybin and lsd in 2014 suresh
received a prestigious rutherford
discovery fellowship and returned to the
university of auckland where he works in
the school of pharmacy at the faculty of
medical and health sciences and leads
the auckland
neuropsychopharmacology research group
saresh's main research interests are in
understanding how therapies alter brain
function and behavior
and in testing methodologies to measure
these changes in both healthy
individuals and patient groups
particularly in depressed patients and
of course this session will have a focus
on mental health so we will delve into
that at the university of auckland he
has conducted clinical trials in
depressed patients involving ketamine
polymine and transcranial magnetic
stimulation
tms he has received several health
research council of new zealand research
grants to support this work including a
grant to investigate the effects of
microdoses of lsd on brain and cognitive
function suresh has published 117 papers
and his work has received more than 8
000 citations suresh
welcome to the session thanks for being
here and taking the time my pleasure tim
nice to see you hopefully i didn't
butcher the name too badly and i will
start with trendlines and perhaps just
an overview of where we sit currently
and perhaps you could just take some
time to describe
mental health and or addiction
statistics trend lines in new zealand
that may be a meaningful place to start
and serve as a canvas upon which we can
discuss other things so new zealand has
pretty good data on this because every
year the minister of health runs a
survey called the new zealand health
survey and they've asked for a long time
about psychological distress and the
amount of psychological distress that
the adult population is experiencing so
so in terms of trend line so this is
conducted every year so in
2011-12 when the survey was conducted
4.6
of adults experienced psychological
distress in the last month and we've
seen that slowly creeping up to the last
data point from
2021 2020 where it was now at 9.6 so
we've seen a doubling over the last 10
years and the amount of adults
experiencing psychological distress
which is
anxiety depression or
sort of psychological fatigue so it's
more than doubled and actually the last
and covet is definitely going to impact
on that we see a little bump on the last
one from the first sort of impact to the
first wave of covert and those lockdowns
and i expect that that's going to only
get worse when the next year's data
point comes out because in new zealand
you might not be aware of new zealand
the second lockdown was quite hard that
just finished at the end of 2021 so that
will definitely have impacted on
people's mental well-being so we'll
expect that to go up so it's not it's
not a good place to run but so it's not
just covert it's been trending up for a
long time and it's not getting any
better and i would imagine although i
don't want to assume that the
costs right and there are many different
types of costs but the healthcare costs
of
these upward trend lines with mental
health issues let's just call them
depression chronic anxiety treatment
resistant depression
are if anything like the united states
quite high in in new zealand as well not
to mention the the personal costs
let's talk about just a few compounds
first and actually his way of background
could you mention just a few other
classes of compounds that you've also
done research with because i think it's
important to note that you have done
more than study
what we would consider to be
psychedelics so perhaps you could just
give a bit of context there yeah so my
background is in general
psychopharmacology so before studying
psychedelics and concurrently to
studying psychedelics i've spent a lot
of time studying anesthetics and
gabaergic drugs so gabaergic drugs tend
to be kind of sedative so alcohol is a
gabaergic drug
benzodiazepines a lot of the anesthetics
like propofol
so i've studied all those drugs at
various times various anti-epileptic
drugs so that kind of class of drugs and
then also
we recently did a study of scopolamine
which is a muscarinic drug and remy
fentanyl we've looked at in the past
i've done a lot of psychopharmacology
studies that have nothing to do with
psychedelics although
the psychedelic studies are the ones
that probably i'm most well known for in
the public discourse because they
attract some interest i suppose
they catch the attention so we're gonna
talk about
the contrast between say ketamine and
traditional or classical psychedelics
but before we get there because i am
personally very curious
why did you decide to study scopolamine
and
what did you find in terms of his its
effects on
conditions whether depression or
otherwise because scopolamine for those
who don't know
is also naturally occurring in many
plants that are considered psychoactive
or a hallucinogenic some of which
are considered quite risky but
how did you determine
this as a as a subject of interest for
for research
we had been doing studies on the
anti-depressant effects of ketamine and
we'll talk about this later but you see
this rapid antidepressant effect and so
what we were interested in was are there
other compounds out there that might
show a similar rapid antidepressant
effects and there was a series of
studies that came out of the nih
intramural program there was two or
three intravenous scopolamine studies
that appeared to show a similar sort of
pattern of antidepressant effects so and
scopolamine is
works very differently to ketamine or
other antidepressants being a muscarinic
antagonist so we thought well that's
really interesting if that works then we
can study that
and even though it's got a completely
different kind of receptor binding
mechanism that we could investigate that
and then potentially look at in our
study we looked at anti-depression and
then if we could then identify
neurobiological markers that would go
along with that then we would sort of
have a converging theory of maybe what
causes rapid antidepressant responses
the downside of course is that we found
no antidepressant response in that
study but you know that that's the data
right we uh we did a really carefully
controlled study we unlike the previous
research that used a inactive placebo
and we'll get back into this we use an
active placebo a compound called
glycopyronium that's used a lot in
surgery that doesn't cross the
blood-brain barrier but still is
anti-muscarinic and it creates a
slightly drowsy feeling and dry mouth
and a lot of the kind of side effects
that you might get
we were able to show that participants
could no longer distinguish which of the
drugs they that they had and actually
we are ascribing most of the
antidepressant response that we see to a
placebo response so listen learned
yeah that's fascinating yes kapalamine i
don't want to take us too off track but
has some very interesting
effects on memory or at least is thought
to have some very interesting effects on
producing amnesia yes it does yeah
while still having a agency on some
level it's a fascinating compound so
let's jump to ketamine most people or
say many people have perhaps heard of
ketamine
very commonly used and please correct me
if i get any of the terminology
incorrect but
anesthetic dissociative anesthetic does
not suppress respiration at least at the
doses that i'm familiar with it is very
widely used in medicine i believe it's
one of the the world health
organization's top 100 most essential
medicines
could you discuss ketamine and classical
psychedelics and
how they differ and just from an
anecdotal perspective although there's a
lot of really good research which of
course you've been a part of looking at
the antidepressant effects of ketamine i
know multiple people now who would
credit their lives being saved to
ketamine and
part of what makes it so fascinating to
me is not that it's a silver bullet that
works for all people but it's the
rapid onset
of some of the effects in certain
subjects compared to say
traditional
or conventional ssris which in some
folks it can take
six to eight weeks say to exert those
types of effects if the people respond
at all so could you just perhaps give us
a primer on ketamine and classical
psychedelics and how they differ because
both can be described as having
psychedelic effects
maybe the easiest thing to start with is
with this classical psychedelics because
it's
relatively simple compared to ketamine
so lsd and cytosine dmt they all seem to
work through a common receptor called
the serotonin 2a receptor and we think
that most of their effect you know
there's probably some other receptors
involved in parts the response but
overwhelmingly we think that most of
that sort of psychedelic experience is
generated from this serotonin 2a
receptor and binding there so
conversely ketamine has a very different
even though it has these kind of this
dissociative or psychedelic effects its
receptor binding sites are many and
complicated so principally
binds to
antagonizes receptor called the nmda
receptor and that's a glutamate receptor
so glutamate is the most common
neurotransmitter in the brain and we
don't hear about it a lot and the nmda
receptor is kind of interesting because
it's actually the receptor that's really
heavily involved in neuroplasticity and
something called long-term potentiation
so that's essentially how brain cells
it's a receptor involved in how brain
cells learn to communicate and
strengthen synapses so that is really
important there but then
it also has a host of other effects so
it binds to gaba receptors those are
kind of the ones involved in inhibition
and sedation it also
binds to opiate receptors and if when
we're familiar with opiates and then
there's other monoamine sites like that
it interacts with serotonin dopamine
norepinephrine
hcn channels sodium channels it just the
list goes on and on as you go up through
the concentration so it's an extremely
complicated pharmacology and it goes
even worse because actually ketamine
metabolizes into nor hydroxyketamine
which has neuroactive sites as well and
also most compounds
exist in the left and right state
they're called racemic so there's a left
and a right state and so there we have s
ketamine and r ketamine and normal
ketamine is both of those but actually
the r and s ketamines probably have
different receptor binding profiles
in addition to all of that so what we're
left with is a stew
you could either call it a very rich
drug or you could call it a dirty drug
depending on your perspective
it's very promiscuous in terms of its
receptor affinity
could you explain for a second two
things so the first is
why scientists would wade into this soup
of variables clinically from the
perspective of mental health what makes
it interesting
and then second what an antagonist does
just for people who may not have that
vocabulary
when drugs are in the brain you know
broadly speaking it's more complicated
but broadly speaking an antagonist is
something that blocks the activity of
something that is going on so
an nmda antagonist blocks the nmda
receptor so it stops glutamate working
there
in terms of
for ketamine in terms of this there's
both a clinical and a scientific
interest there that's and they're both
really interesting to study which is why
i've been studying ketamine for now 10
years now the
clinical significance is what you
mentioned before you have you can take
patients into the lab patients that have
had treatment resistant depression
unremitting for years and years and
years and you can give them a ketamine
infusion and they'll get this really
rapid remission and symptoms and that
would manifest itself in hours now
people will know ketamine is a street
drug right and they would say oh well
maybe that's just because the person's
high you know that they've been
experiencing this intoxication
so
my response to that would be well
actually you know if you then measure
the person's depression symptoms at 24
hours after the ketamine infusion you'll
see that they're still not depressed now
what we know about the pharmacokinetics
that's how long ketamine lasts in the
body the half-life's about four hours
for ketamine so at the hour time point
there's really no ketamine left in the
body at all so ketamine's gone they
haven't been high
for you know 20 20 22 hours so they're
not high anymore the ketamine is
entirely the body but they're still not
depressed and then what that shows is
that
the ketamine has changed something in
their brain so this caused some kind of
functional change in the brain and that
suggests and to move them from a
depressed to a non-depressed state so
that's really interesting that there's
kind of like a
switch in there that actually can be
clicked and this ketamine's obviously
working on some kind of target
that can flick that switch and that
understanding what that is
scientifically is really interesting and
and while other things can flick that
switch they do it much slower like ssris
they switch it in maybe four to six
weeks or transcranial tms transcranial
magnetic stimulation that might take a
month to work as well but here we can
switch in a day for a scientist it's
really um interesting because you can
run at really good experiments because
you no longer have to wait six weeks and
all these extraneous variables that get
in the way of your interpretations you
can just
go depressed non-depressed within a day
and that leads to really tight
experimental design
so i want to preface what i'm about to
say
with
the
statement
which is i know that the plural of
anecdote does not equal data nonetheless
i do think case studies are interesting
and i i can speak to one very cute
example friend of mine in law
enforcement who was suicidal he had
acute suicidal ideation and
many people in law enforcement or in the
military pilots would be another
category
are very hesitant to
admit to
any type of mental challenges or to seek
treatment because it can result in
leaves of absence and basically
penalties professionally speaking and
ketamine
did exert those rapid effects and
again not to say that this should be the
expectation for every patient but there
are people who
i know who go in
acutely suicidal and have come out
literally saying i don't know what i was
so upset about i don't know how i was so
concerned about xyz and
what i'd love to ask you next just again
to contrast the say classical
psychedelics and you mentioned a number
of them which are in this a tryptamine
class we probably won't get into the
phenethylamines and mescaline and mda
and so on which which can be very
different
in some of their subjective effects but
if we just if we're looking at say lsd
psilocybin
and then ketamine if you look at the
durability of some of the effects say
for anti-depression what is your
personal perspective on how they might
differ in why they have durable effects
and i raised this because i was recently
in a conversation with roland griffiths
from
johns hopkins medicine who's done a lot
of work with psilocybin and also
john crystal at yale who's done a lot of
work with ketamine and you know roland's
perspective was that he he thinks a lot
of the durability of anti-depression
effects
six months 12 months of follow-up let's
just say
have a lot to do with a change in
content meaning that people are actually
able not just to
suppress the symptoms of
depression
but to address some of the kind of root
narratives that are leading to
depression
he was less sure about ketamine and
maybe there's sort of more of a
mechanistic
explanation
like neurogenesis or increasing dendrite
growth where it's sort of fixing the
machinery so to speak on some level what
are your perspectives
the background to this for people is
that the antidepressant response that we
see to a ketamine infusion you know that
will last any you know in our
experiences anywhere from a day or two
to a couple of weeks to a month
whereas the data for like the psilocybin
that seems to indicate yeah like months
half a year year-long anti-wrist
responses
but
i think it this kind of falls into the
we don't know
pile
from a data perspective because the
models that have been used the
experiments have been done between
ketamine
versus the classical psychedelics have
been really different in terms of the
therapeutic approaches tried so
when people have been doing these
cytocybin assisted therapies they've
been wrapping around an intense amount
of psychotherapy right so
it's and i think it's really important
for people to understand when they think
about because that you know you just
read these headlines as you know
stylists haven't improved depression
well actually it's not just cytoside but
it's the fact that the person's gone
into this psychotherapy regimen you know
with a therapist and they've done hours
of preparation for the experience the
therapist has sat through them through
the experience and then they've spent
hours and days on integration afterwards
so it's probably about 40 hours of
psychotherapy for one one solid seven
course so it's not just the drug alone
it's psyched up assisted psychotherapy
now whereas the model for ketamine
that's mostly being used is basically
and the way it seems to be used off
label is that people just go into a
ketamine clinic and they smash an
infusion for an hour and they go away
and there hasn't really been much
studies where
people have actually done ketamine
assisted psychotherapy and tried to well
what if we do
wrap that similar lip what would happen
if we wrapped that similar level of
psychotherapeutic support around
ketamine would that make that ketamine
response
now stretch out beyond two weeks to
maybe a similar kind of time force
because the people in the cyber world
have come from that kind of more
traditional psychedelic assisted therapy
world and the people that have been
studying ketamine have come from more of
a kind of traditional psychiatry world
and so we haven't we don't really i'm
not aware of any data that really has
kind of tried to
find them the man in the middle or or
strip back side of seidman to just side
aside then which i think people would
ethically struggle with trying to do
that kind of experiment do you say that
just because of the difficulties that
can come up in navigating that
experience
yeah because you know these uh um
so something like psilocybin is very
powerful in terms of suicidal dmt i'll
see these very powerful psychological
effects and they can be destabilizing
for people so people need to be well
prepared that they're going to
experience very unusual profound
potentially disturbing things and
to not provide that preparation might be
not be ethical distribute back to
nothing like it's done for kid i mean
right then there's probably a middle
point where it could be stripped down to
sort of the minimal
viable support on the front side and
then still provide the support on the
post session side
and this also highlights for me you know
the i don't know
that we are really in a in a very
fertile nascent
period of psychedelic research and even
though studies were conducted much
earlier say in the 60s
they don't really
meet our standards for
study design that we would have today
and certainly with the imaging
techniques that you have fmri and and
others that are now at hand
you can examine these these tools with a
set of lenses that you couldn't before
and it's really been astonishing to me
to see how
far very little money can go in this
space compared to perhaps other areas
like oncology or cardiology for instance
could you speak to how you pick your
studies for instance the lsd micro
dosing study why did you choose
to
pursue that study
so i had returned to new zealand in 2015
and having previously done classical
psychology so i went my and i started my
research group here i thought well this
we'll start with ketamine because it's
approved it'll be he's reasonably easy
to get approval for and no one's going
to blink too many eyelids about a new
guy coming into town wanting to study
ketamine new guy coming to town wanted
to do lsd is probably going to
fluffle a few more feathers around the
faculty i would have thought back in
those days but having sort of built a
bit of a reputation i decided it was
time to get back into doing some
classical psychedelic research now the
micro dosing
specifically was well yeah
no one had really looked at microdosing
in a rct at that point and it's a
randomized control trial randomized
control trial and i guess does should we
explain what microdosing is maybe
first why don't you explain what that is
and it also might segue into
one of the design challenges meaning
placebo control yeah
psychedelics overall so yes please
define micro dosing yeah so microdosing
is
when people take very low doses of
psychedelics about the tenth the dose of
a big dose of uh when people are gonna
tripping so you know people might trip
on like you know 150 micrograms lsd but
from micro dose they might take 10
micrograms say it's about a 10th and it
causes well we don't really know exactly
what it causes yet because we haven't
studied it properly but
users report that they have improved
mental well-being concentration
increases
so what they do is they take these
microdoses maybe every third day is the
most common schedule that's called this
was popularized by james vaderman who
wrote a book in 2011 and it's really
taken off since then you know like
before 2011 not many people were doing
it and there was really not much
consciousness about it but now we're
seeing hundreds of thousands probably of
people around the world now microdosing
you look at the the size of the reddit
forum subscriptions just going up and up
and up so there's a huge amount of
people out there microdosing these
classical psychedelics every third day
many are giving up their antidepressant
medications to do this but there's
really no clinical trial evidence about
it and not even in mental health
patients just not anything now the
reason that is is because if you wanted
to run a proper rct proper randomized
control trial of
microdosing a psychedelic then you have
to prescribe a class a substance a
schedule one substance for people to
take home
and
most
legal systems won't allow you to do that
i don't think you could do that in the
united states i don't think the dea is
going to be very happy about i think
could be i think they might be a little
grumpy about that yeah yeah and so
there's not many jurisdictions where
that could be done so
however there is one jurisdiction where
it can be done legally and that's a
little old new zealand so as i
was as you do every now and then read
the uh reading the mysteries of drugs
regulations from 1977 and the misuse of
drugs act that goes along with it
we'll kind of discover this loophole i
don't know if you call it lupo where
actually uh
we are allowed to prescribe class a
substances it's not ever really been
done but it's just sitting in the
legislation saying that this is allowed
to be done so we
engaged in a long process with the
ministry of health and provided a legal
reasoning for why this could be done and
so we did it and replied
to
them and got the appropriate approvals
from ministry various parts of the
ministry to do it and
that allowed us to
run the study that we've just finished
collecting data for which was to give 80
healthy volunteers a six week lsd
microdosing course to where they would
take the first one in the laboratory and
there are other 13 doses that were taken
out in the wild as it were much like
people do in real life
so let's let's dig into that a little
bit so were they given the other 13
doses to take home all at once or do
they come back to get one at a time or
two at a time
they were given packs of four four and
five so we never gave them like 130 140
30 micrograms to take home so that they
couldn't just stack them all up but
actually you know there's a lot of like
theoretical concern about this but
actually to get into one of our trials
participants have to do multiple
screening sessions they spend hours
getting scanned and having all sorts of
probes attached to their body to record
all their physiology getting
pricked with needles and blood taken and
all sorts of stuff right in
hours and hours
there are a lot more efficient ways to
get doses of lsd
oh for sure for sure yeah absolutely and
we track we track every single dose was
administered and video recorded by the
participants and sent to us so we knew
there was a hundred percent adherence to
the protocol
and
part of the reason that i've been
engaging with science in new zealand is
precisely
for this reason i mean you have on some
levels a very agile
ecosystem compared to
the united states and you have
legislation that would allow you to even
consider designing a study like this
could you speak to
how new zealand
can or does foster scientific and
research innovation
you could speak to certainly what you've
already mentioned any regulatory
differences but what else makes new
zealand unique what else could make new
zealand unique and
we can go from there i'd love to hear
what else is happening in new zealand
that you find interesting from a
scientific standpoint
in this domain but let's begin with how
does or how can new zealand foster
scientific and research innovation
we have a strong regulatory environment
so i'm not saying our regulatory
environment is weak it's strong but it's
it's capable of being agile and it's
small when we're a small country so it's
possible to just
ring the person up who's involved in
this that or the next thing whereas in
another place you might be trapped
behind five layers of bureaucracy to
these hidden figures that you know
making these decisions in a country of
five million is only so many people who
know are involved in these kind of
decisions
so if you are sensible and polite and
appropriate you can ask questions and
and get things to move so with small
size i think does come agility and and i
know that there are certainly
pharmaceutical companies that are
investing into new zealand's
psychedelics industry and our general
medical
into clinical trials here we're an
attractive place to run clinical trials
because also we're relatively cheap in
terms of
what you can get on a per dollar basis
compared to what you might get in europe
or united states so so that's attractive
we do have a good regulatory environment
in terms of how we can promote more sort
of innovation i think
at the moment the government does take
reasonably hands-off approach
particularly in this area it's taken a
completely hands-off approach it is so
by comparison and where we risk falling
behind by comparison australia they
created a 15 million dollar fund
specifically for these sort of
breakthrough mental health therapeutics
to kind of prime the pump because you do
need a certain amount of capacity you
need a certain amount of infrastructure
you need people so they've set that up
as a pump priming exercise really to
sort of provide all the capability they
need so we haven't seen any signs of
that yet from government that there
would actually be sort of a more
dedicated funding pathway now we are
able to get funding but we have to go
into the general pop funding so we have
to compete with all the cancer
researchers and the heart researchers
which does mean that when we do stuff
and get funds
that our workers are very high has to be
of very high quality because we're
competing with our peers that are you
know doing very high quality stuff so we
know when we get funded that what we're
doing is rigorous
yeah so good news is there are
regulatory frameworks and federal
funding for this type of work bad news
you don't have something like the nimh i
think it's the national institute on
mental health in the united states which
might
give grants specifically to this type of
work you have to compete against
every researcher in
any given medical field who is seeking
funding yeah that's right and it yeah
and there's actually some there's
actually some data on that and actually
what we've seen and not just
psychedelics just mental health in
general has been underfunded in new
zealand for very mental health research
let alone treatment services mental
health research has been underfunded in
new zealand relative to
the burden of disease that we see in the
country so there are some parts things
like neurology has been
relatively speaking over funded and
we've spent a huge amount of research
dollars on things like neurology
and cancer and heart they've actually
relative to the burning disease they've
done very well but actually mental
health relative to the burden of disease
we're seeing the population this can be
quantified using um disability adjusted
life years and you can look at research
income relative to disability adjusted
life is and mental health has not been
given the funding needs so there's an
argument that new zealand does need to
carve out specific not psychedelics but
mental health research
to make sure that we're
getting that research done to serve the
disability that we're seeing in the
population and the health needs
do you have something equivalent in new
zealand to
break through therapy designation and i
ask because the fda here in the u.s has
granted both psilocybin
and
mdma assisted psychotherapy
breakthrough therapy designation for
depression different types of depression
and
ptsd post-traumatic stress disorder
respectively
do you see ways that the new zealand
government could foster
innovation and more experimentation with
some type of designation
like that or for instance i'm sitting
here in the state of texas in the united
states which for those who don't know is
generally thought to be a very
conservative place but nonetheless there
was legislation recently passed
both by the republican
so let's just call it conservative and
liberal parties to get state funding set
aside for psychedelic research related
to veterans for instance
and that was bipartisan and that will be
coming online soon do you see any
particular tools or approaches that new
zealand might use to further foster what
is
i think what already is pretty vibrant
ecosystem but it could certainly do
quite a bit more what are your thoughts
i think the latter would be the way to
go so i think in terms of things like
breakthrough designation we don't have
we in new zealand sit at the end of the
pipeline for when treatments come
because
the way our treatments come as you know
an international pharmaceutical company
will apply for registration here and
they'll use all the data basically
they've submitted to the fda so you know
once they've got fda or ema approval
then they might come here for approval
after a few years and they bother to put
the marketing application together so
we're kind of at the back end of that
kind of process here and that's why we
have in new zealand sadly a relatively
weak pharmacopoeia where a lot of drugs
that are available in the us or europe
aren't available here because they're
just not marketed here because we're a
small market so i don't see that
that first approach worked but the
second approach could certainly work
where
you know the government sets aside
legislation probably won't be through
legislation would direct one of its
funding
bodies
to sort of you know to say and it does
this for other areas of research it says
okay let's let's fund this let's fund
this uh things like growing up in new
zealand so new zealand has a really good
history of funding longitudinal research
so there's the dunedin study and the
christchurch study and now growing up in
new zealand we've got really strong
longitudinal studies that have been
going on for like 40 50 years that have
been centrally funded
that would be a mechanism that could
certainly work
yeah i'm very excited about new zealand
as the
the tip of the spear for studies along
the lines of what you have done you and
your team have done with the lsd micro
dosing study where you have the ability
to pilot
and innovate in a way that is simply not
possible in some larger places like the
united states
and on some level similar to the way
that
large global brands in some cases even
though you might be last
in line or at the back of the line for
certain types of say
global drugs that are available
elsewhere you also have companies like i
want to say adidas and nike and so on
who will actually do pilot studies
and launches in new zealand because you
have
sort of all of the ingredients
for english-speaking first world
country with incredible research
faculties and i mean in this particular
application they're looking at
commercial interest but you can pilot
and run experiments on a small or
longitudinal basis that you can then
apply elsewhere which i think is
incredible so it's a huge gift that new
zealand also has to offer the world in a
sense
who are other
scientific inspirations inside of new
zealand are there other scientists who
you think are doing particularly
interesting work could be limited to
psychedelics or adjacent compounds or
could be applied really really any
anywhere else yeah well you know there's
a new zealand has a rich biomedical
tradition so yeah i work in a general
medical faculty so the people sitting
next to me are doing you know cancer
research or you know so we have a really
amazing people doing work in a place in
auckland called the liggins institute
where they're doing work on preterm
babies and they do really amazing
interventional work there there's also
really strong stroke research happening
in new zealand looking at how stroke
recovery research is doing really well
in new zealand and down down in otago i
really like the group down there that
are doing in the more psychedelic space
they're doing for glue has been doing a
huge amount of work with ketamine and
then various ketamine analogues that and
different ketamine formulations that
they've been working at and so there's a
lot of there's quite a rich
group of research happening down at
otago as well so i guess it's
mostly centered around where the two
medical schools are located in new
zealand is where they're kind of where
things are happening in the biomedical
realm
what do you find interesting with are
there any particular ketamine analogs
that you find interesting and maybe you
could just define what that means
for a minute and i also wanted just to
refer to something you mentioned earlier
you were talking about the metabolites
of ketamine being
bioactive or psychoactive themselves
just for those who have a general
interest in psychedelics this is true
for a lot of compounds i mean it's true
for ibogaine and nori began and so on
which certainly makes them more
interesting to study but what is academy
and analog and are there any analogs or
approaches to analogs that you find
particularly interesting
maybe it's not an analog one of the
things is they've been looking at like
slow release formulations as there's one
way to go right to see if they and this
comes back to that thorny issue about
with ketamine like how important is
actually having the psychedelic
experience but if maybe if you could
slow down the absorption of ketamine so
it's not such a hit
but came in slower so there's really
interesting work happening with slow
release formulations there's a new
zealand company who have been looking at
that is douglas pharmaceuticals have
been looking at this kind of slow
release ketamine that's quite
interesting
and then there's different companies
overseas as well looking at i described
that left and right formation they've
been stripping ketamine into its r and s
formulation now janssen as you'll be
aware they took the s part of ketamine
and put that in a nasal spray and so
that they could this is just
yes bravado and this is essentially a
marketing exercise right like there's no
it doesn't seem that it doesn't need has
any more efficacy than normal kidney but
it allowed them to achieve a patent on
it what is the price differential i
think it's something like
one to five dollars generic like several
hundred dollars
usd something like that i mean in new
zealand there's been even bigger the
differential because in new zealand
racemic ketamine is uh pharmac
subsidized so we can get a vial of
ketamine for like twenty dollars or
something but of course this provider
was like five or six thousand dollars so
it's just the differences are insane but
you know
for a clinician who may not be
comfortable with prescribing ketamine
off label because ketamine is not
indicated for depression it's an
off-label treatment and because it's a
controlled substance people you know
there are clinicians that get you know
antsy about that and and fair enough but
that ketamine is ketamine is allowed to
be prescribed on label that may make
things easier the problem with ketamine
the only reason ketamine is not probably
is because because it's a generic
compound i guess this is a sort of
background on how medicines get approved
is you need a company to sponsor the
research to go to new zealand to go to
med safe and say look here are all our
data ketamine should be indicated for
depression but no company is going to do
that for ketamine because it's just too
expensive and basically any generic
competitor can just come and make more
ketamine and and sell it instead so
there's no return on investment to be
head there with intellectual property
yeah let's talk for a second if you
wouldn't mind expanding on paul glue and
his work a bit
because i think some of it
may give indications for
other approaches that can be taken by
researchers to do this type of work
would you mind just elaborating a bit on
what type of work he's doing yeah so
he's been looking at he's been doing a
slow release but the other thing he's
been looking at is other internalizing
disorders so he's done a lot of work
looking at ketamine and anxiety disorder
so and he's starting to build up quite a
good evidence base that ketamine
might not just have efficacy in
depression but in a range of sort of
room and internalizing disorders so i
think he's done anxiety and social
anxiety so ketamine is seems to
have
therapeutic effects beyond just the
category of depression these are all
kind of there's less data on these at
the moment so there's you would be even
more reluctant to prescribe off label
for those things where there's a small
evidence base but there is an emerging
evidence space that other things and
paul's definitely been contributing to
that
and i wanted to also for people who may
not have familiarity with
the
odd medley of indications that
psychedelics can be used for
first of all i would recommend to those
who haven't read it how to change your
mind by michael pollan gives a pretty
good overview you know some of it would
be contested like the importance of the
default mode network and the down
regulation of such in some of these
experiences but
it would appear and certainly that i
think a lot of data would support this
but the case studies themselves also
would that
the
let's just say dsm described in our
parlance over here at least i'm not sure
if you guys have an equivalent of a
dsm use the d for insurance yeah yeah
for insurance reimbursement purposes you
need a
an indication and a code right so you
could have anorexia nervosa you could
have obsessive compulsive disorder or
whatever the latest
rephrase of that is alcohol use disorder
right otherwise known as alcoholism etc
etc
and what is plausibly the case is that
these conditions actually share a lot of
common dna so to speak because
there are certainly studies being run
right now and this is not to say that
psychedelics are panacea at all that's
not the point i'm making but
that from opiate use disorder to
anorexia nervosa to
ocd
to chronic anxiety there may be shared
characteristics such as a rigidity in
thought looping or patterning that are
interrupted by these tools which then
provide a
window of plasticity within which you
can do very very interesting things
which then begs the question that we
were discussing a little earlier of how
much the therapeutic wrapper
impacts the
clinical outcomes so if you're heating
up
the clay so to speak and adding some
moisture by using these compounds like
who is actually molding is it the
patient is it the therapist is it the
combination of the two is it the
experience itself that's just bathing
your neurons and various
chemicals that produce dendrite growth
part of why this whole field is so
exciting to me is because there's still
so many open questions the answers to
which have
just supremely
potentially important ramifications are
there any particular studies that you
would like to do or see done in the near
future in the next few years
oh there's so
these endless possibilities you know
like
we're only at the really beginning of
what we're doing right we've only been
doing this stuff for like a couple of
years and essentially all the stuff
everything that's been done so far is
essentially just elaborate pilot studies
right we're just beginning to learn and
you know that's come from 50 years of
prohibition where we haven't been able
to do this work so you know things were
looking and people will notice this
might know this history that in 1960s
when this research started slowing down
the early 1960s you know there was
promising signals but everything just
stopped for like almost 50 years and
so we're only just you know a couple of
years into like learning how to do these
kind of studies again so
that means that we've got a lot to learn
and it's going to take a while before we
figure this stuff out because studies
take a long time to do and the other
thing is these are really complicated
interventions you know when you put them
into a clinical trial and you try to
work out what the hell is going on you
know because you alluded the first
problem that we have is diagnosis right
we
unlike for mental health the really
thing to be aware of is unlike
cardiology or cancer right we can't just
like stick someone
get an echocardiogram done and realize
they've got some kind of thing going
wrong with their heart some
regurgitation or valve whatever it is or
we can't measure a tumor size and no
yeah this is it so the physician is
based entirely basically putting aside
some organic issues the diagnosis is
basically just subjective reports of
symptoms and the diagnostic categories
are completely woolly and we don't
understand the biology of what's going
on in terms of the diagnosis and then we
have the problem that we give this
intervention that we have a
only a partial knowledge of what it's
actually doing in the body and then
actually
how we actually measure the clinical
response is also kind of woolly because
we have to use these kind of subjective
scales you know like how are you feeling
i'm feeling better okay you're feeling
better so and we don't yeah which you
know which if you're measuring like you
know tumor size in a petri dish you know
that's uh or tumor growth so we have a
long way to go to harden up the science
but to answer your question more
specifically the interventions
themselves are really complicated we
have this
strong drug intervention with these
therapeutic wraparounds and we have to
start to
systematically deconstruct what's going
on there and start to manipulate some of
those factors as variables so like how
much wraparound therapy do you need the
question that's never really been asked
is well what type of therapy do you
provide or is all therapy the same or is
it just actually like talking to
somebody what is the actual requirements
there to get because you will have no
shortage of case reports like you said
of people that just took cytosim by
themselves and said oh yeah i started
feeling better and with no like thing
not i'm not saying you should do anyone
should do that by the way but just uh
people will report that of course at the
same time people report taking cytoside
and having a terrible experience and
with terrible psychological shock
involved afterwards so
we do have to start to deconstruct
what's actually going on in intervention
so these are long complicated
experiments that require a lot of people
a lot of manpower and each
intervention is really complicated so
each data point is like gold dust to
collect
yeah absolutely so i want to add just a
little bit of commentary for people who
don't have the history so you mentioned
the prohibition meaning the banning of
common use of these substances for 50
plus years
and i would say at least when we look at
the case in the united states that it
was mostly if not entirely for political
reasons as opposed to scientific reasons
and one can really
learn quite a lot about the history
including nixon and other colorful
characters
like
like leary and so on and so forth but
the
punishment didn't really fit the crime
in the sense and that's my perspective
that
if you look at the say ld50 so the dose
at which 50 of a given
subset of the population would be
expected to die of overdose for these
compounds
you have incredibly high if not unknown
ceilings for a lot of them right i mean
they're physiologically
very innocuous compared to even
something like acetaminophen for
instance where at least in the us i
don't know about new zealand but the
rate of er admission emergency room
admissions for acetaminophen is through
the roof it's got to be top 10. that is
not to say that there are not
significant psychological implications
particularly for those who are generally
going to be excluded by study criteria
like those with family history of of
schizophrenia and we're going to jump
into into q a in about five minutes but
what i would like to just make note of
really quickly is that
i feel the
lsd micro dosing study that you just
finished gathering data for
is a really important first of its kind
and please poke holes in this if i'm
getting any of it wrong
for a number of different reasons but
i'd like to highlight one of them and
one of them is placebo control
in psychedelic
studies or studies involving
psychedelics where
it's incredibly difficult to
have placebo controls at larger doses
with something like psilocybin or lsd
because it is it is tremendously obvious
to anyone who has taken it that they've
taken it and if they haven't taken it
it's very clear that they have not taken
it and there's going to be expectancy
effects and generally people are going
to come in knowing on some level what
psychedelics are or believing that they
do and having done some reading and so
on right
so you have placebo effects we won't
even get into nocebo effects which
people should read up on because that's
also something worth looking at but in
the case of micro dosing
it seems like you really can
begin to apply placebo
controls
and
just for people listening could you
describe how you thought about that and
whether you decided on passive or active
placebo
for this study we went with the inactive
placebo just because
because no one ever done lsd microdosing
before we wanted a rent for
in the community we wanted a inactive
control
so that when we looked at safety and
like physiological measures of safety we
had a really
we've not actually done anything to
these people we haven't given them any
drug this is just pure so we had a very
pure safety group to look at
and in terms of alice whether people are
you know
able to detect the effects some are some
are so we are around the threshold this
was at around 10 micrograms yes about 10
micrograms in male volunteers so there
was quite a heteronory though actually
we saw that some participants were
particularly sensitive to it and we had
to reduce doses for some participants
and some hardly noticed so there's quite
a variability in people's response and
that's interesting in and of itself it
suggests to me that we're probably
when we move on to the next phase and
actually wanting to look at a clinical
population and run like a for example a
depression trial we may need to start
looking at lightly active placebos
because we're now interested in the
clinical outcome not just sort of like
can you do it what do people experience
if we're wanting to kind of try to fool
people a bit better then
probably some kind of light placebo the
little bit of i wouldn't say deception
but just ambiguity in the information
that we provide to participants might be
enough to get us over the top
in terms of blinding the study
successfully unlike psychedelic studies
which aren't
blinded at all and this is a real
methodological problem that the field
has to try to conquer in some way and
we're working on it i just want to jump
in for a second so i would say also that
the the fact that placebo controls are
so difficult
is
i don't want to say a feature and not a
bug because it does present just from
the standpoint of rigor and publication
a whole lot of challenges but the fact
that this effectively entire class of
drugs has so much trouble with placebo
controls is very interesting in and of
itself
i've written a whole mess of paper
yeah i mean it's fascinating that it's
so hard do you have any and you don't
have to give away your secrets but
anything on the short list for potential
active placebos that would you would use
in such a case
niacin
nice thing about niacin's not a great
option that's um yeah a vitamin so
actually niacin was used in the 1960s
and it's been determined even in 1960
that niacin is a poor control for
society but people used to use it for
some reason and i'm not sure why skin
flushing i mean maybe some type of
subjective experience that people think
it's doing something yeah that's why
it's added to a lot of dietary
supplements as well
we're getting into the weeds here but
what i would say is actually what the
compound is isn't as important
as what the participant thinks it's
going it's their belief about what
they're receiving that's the important
thing because
blinding in clinical trials is really
important to prevent expectancy since
it's because if a person goes into a
clinical trial thinking they're going to
get side to side when they do get
cytocyber and if they think it might
make them better they work out that
they've had it and they go up and maybe
that over insulin over accentuates their
clinical response which we would call a
compound so that's potentially a problem
so but what's important is it's not the
compound itself it's what the
participant believes that they've had
and so
it's not as much potentially around what
the actual act of placebo is but what
you tell the participant about the
active placebo and the information that
you provide them
because you're not trying to manipulate
your physiology you're trying to
manipulate their beliefs about what
they're having so i think these are
subtle things that we need to really
think about in our experimental designs
you know this is why i really enjoy
doing research in this here because
these are fascinating problems and it's
a really like fascinating area to try
and work out these scientific problems
i reckon we can do it i'm not you know
give me another 10 or 15 years and i
might give up but right now i think you
know we can totally crack it if we put
our brains to it as a scientific
discipline
it's a really exciting time to be
for me certainly observing watching to
the extent that i can supporting
the ecosystem and a really exciting time
for people like you to be doing the
research it's really
kind of a blue sky opportunity and the
payoffs
as i think we established very early on
in the conversation are potentially huge
if we look at the
trend lines of various diagnoses and
illnesses and
the costs both on a personal level
familial level and societal level so
let's jump to q a at this point
if that makes sense and i'll hop over to
michelle to see if you have any any
questions for us i think we have quite a
few we do actually
yeah we've got heaps of questions here
what i'm going to do though stress is i
want to start it off first question is
going to be
an ask so you can put your ask out there
to the audience because someone has said
is how can we speed this up what can be
done to make the benefits of this coming
forward a lot quicker i think
you know we've got plenty of awareness
around mental health generally in new
zealand i think we haven't seen
government or any signals from funders
and i think that's where we haven't
really seen any kind of movement so
that's where pressure can potentially be
applied there's not much in the way of
like foundational advocacy for this kind
of stuff in new zealand or there's not a
huge amount of push to like
make government do anything about it so
i think it's probably where things can
be accelerated is by trying to get
government to start paying attention and
for them to take the attitude that we
can be at the forefront in new zealand
we can be at the forefront of this and
we already are like we're way betting
above our in terms of like us being this
tiny little country is back into the
world we are betting way above our way
and we could get onto the front of these
things being introduced if they are
appropriate to be introduced but a few
bit more push from government would
potentially accelerate that and you know
and really establish us as leaders in
the field
stress just to piggyback on that for
those in the audience who might want to
support in a philanthropic capacity
certainly i've been interested in the
space for a long time it's deeply
affected my life and the lives of of
many i know and the science is important
at the end of the day
to push the ball forward so whether with
you at university of auckland or at the
university of otago there are some
interesting things happening in new
zealand are there any recommendations
you might have for people who
would like to consider supporting
philanthropically
uh yeah in terms of philanthropics what
the best thing is to get in touch with
either myself or paul
we don't we're not top secret uh things
and you know this there's plenty of
mechanisms you know but what i would say
is that certainly philanthropic money is
really important and you know the
funding that you provided us was like
essentially seed money that we could use
to
then get the feasibility you need to
then get a government grant to do the
research to establish
you know to establish that you know we
can run this trial we can do it because
when you have nothing you just can't get
started and you apply for grant this and
then the grant people say well you can't
do this you can't do that you haven't
shown us that you can do this that in
the next thing and then they turn your
grant away right so
philanthropic money can also be seen as
a c not just as you're funding the whole
thing but as a seed for future
investment so definitely yeah that's so
important
i just want to say it again
that
not only do you sort of punch above your
weight class
in the research that i've seen so far
but
the amount of money that you commit from
a philanthropic standpoint can also have
much
more impact and sort of amplifying
effect as a signal right because then it
allows researchers to fundraise that
much more easily from other sources so
the money is important of course but the
signal is also really important
absolutely
yeah michelle do you have more i'm sure
you do i do yeah so this one um what are
the risks of micro dosing so if it's
patients that are diagnosed with bipolar
or schizophrenia so they're not looking
for a medical advice but just any
general commentary about how safe that
is it and is it dangerous
we have a data set that we have
collected and it's really the first data
set that's been collected and so far we
haven't seen any
negative safety things but it's a very
small data set in a very healthy
population so i think
potentially there are indications
such as schizophrenia or bipolar where
it's possibly not a good idea we know
that high doses of psychedelic can
trigger psychosis occasionally and cause
psychological distress so i think doing
this kind of on your own particularly if
you're trying to treat severe mental
health disorder could be you know uh
you're getting into the unknown i guess
is
that kind of thing so
potentially the biggest risks probably
apply actually in the application area
of mental health and particularly with
particular comorbid disorders so
i think it's important to treat lightly
carefully
i'll add something to that really
quickly which is there are also
questions of provenance and
legitimacy so there are some synthetic
i mean a lot of synthetic
thousands of synthetic psychedelic
compounds that are sometimes confused
with or sold as lsd that can launch you
into some very
at best uncomfortable and at worst very
dangerous circumstances where you could
be in an experience for
24-48 hours
and on top of that it's critical i would
say to consider legal ramifications
there are legal risks if you're dealing
with schedule 1 compounds and secondly
just because i've seen this quite a few
times
we're dealing with in the case of lsd
for instance micrograms okay so to
explain what that means suresh please
correct me i'm getting this wrong you've
got
let's just say milligrams which are a
thousandth of a gram am i right so far
yep milligrams is thousands yeah and
microgram is a millionth of a gram
if i'm getting that right or is that a
yep
yep so if you're dealing with millionths
of a gram
even the albert hoffman is the father of
lsd i mean went on his first famous
huge trip while bicycle riding because
he got on his fingers and so you're
dealing with such incredibly small
quantities that the ability to misdose
or to absorb it through the skin can
lead to something that is most certainly
not a micro dosing experience and if
you're doing it without supervision and
you happen to get in a car expecting it
to be a micro dose for instance that
could be very very tragic indeed so i
just thought to be the stern dad about
it all but felt the need to know that
these are absolutely true that the
non-physiological risks are probably far
greater than the physiological risks and
even though law enforcement deals with
things like digital c classes like
cannabis relatively lightly these days
actually they're not so forgiving with
schedule one substances so that is
important to bear in mind and i forget
often yeah that you're absolutely right
again about this purity of supply and
dosing i mean i forget this because we
have i'd like to say the best lsd in
town in my
lab joking aside yeah like
illicitly in pain dallas d or psilocybin
could be cut with other things
it's very hard to know
but we do have drug treating services in
new zealand that can provide that kind
of information though
and i'll just actually that's a really
good point to just add one thing to
which is in the u.s there are services
like dancesafe
and others that will provide drug
testing kits
which is not to say i recommend
illicit use of drugs but the reality is
that people are going to use what they
believe
certain compounds to be and there are
tools also for testing so that you try
to mitigate some of the risk
there's a few people in the audience
that are doing studies themselves in so
toronto and the us
and one of them's about the questions
about open science so what are your
thoughts about open science replication
crisis will you be sharing your data
will you be keeping it private
so it depends on the study and it
depends what you're trying to do so open
sciences is admirable and it's good but
it's not always possible depending on
you know who's suresh could you define
that just for people listening who are
not familiar so open science is um
essentially
sort of releasing your data to the world
when you have it and it goes with
another thing which is called
pre-registration which is basically
publishing your clinical trial protocols
before you actually do the study so my
lab group has definitely started doing
publishing clinical trial protocols
before we do it so
and we've done open science things so
i'm in favor of it where you can do it
but there will be times when you for
example you're doing industry funded
work where that's not possible because
that's intellectual property of of said
company so you know i'm generally in
favor but i think we do end up with open
science of having
a lot of data in the world
but no interpretive framework
we can all do thousands of experiments
and release
terabytes and petabytes of data into the
world with of potentially bad data which
you know hasn't been collected well or
and just adds confusing signals to the
noise so i don't know that it's a
panacea for actually
a deep theoretical understanding of
what's going on
now we'll shift to a training question
so anticipating legislation change and
increasing access to psychedelic
assisted psychotherapy how do we prepare
the workforce
and to be able to provide this
so what training pathways exist already
for psychologists clinical social
workers to upskill and become involved
this is a big controversy
i can take a stab there are a number of
concurrent experiments being run
so
in the united states
a lot of eyes are on oregon
and
within the state of oregon there will be
a lot of action in the next six to 12
months looking at developing effectively
a parallel structure for registering
and
supervising administration of psilocybin
for psilocybin assisted therapies so
that is a very live question for the
state of oregon so i'd encourage people
to
watch that very closely on a political
medical
level
also you know my foundation so the cisa
foundation
s-a-i-s-e-i foundation.org for people
are
interested has
also participated in funding a joint
program which is focused on psychiatry
and this is at hopkins
nyu
yale and possibly a few other
institutions i apologize that i'm
forgetting where
and i'm going to get some of the details
wrong here but in effect a certification
program is being created that can be
applied
into
this
funnel which already exists and that is
the sort of psychiatry md training and
people can elect to then add this type
of training and qualification
to their pre-existing track if that
makes sense
which is not to say that this should be
limited to being administered by mds or
md phds i don't think that will come
close to addressing
the demand and need more importantly the
need
forgetting about healthy normals which
is a whole separate conversation let's
just talk about people with actual sort
of clinical diagnoses
i do expect that there will be
similar experimentation with nursing
schools
i hope there will be also
experimentation within
accredited social work programs
for allowing social workers
but the fact of the matter i think is
that
this is one of the most challenging
issues that will be faced in the next
five years next five to ten years
because
not only
is it necessary to develop a pipeline
for training
but the training is extremely
controversial
because there are people who feel like
the sacred is being secularized and
therefore if there aren't enough
legally trained
let's just say therapists or
facilitators to administer these drugs
that
there will be a lot of gray market and
black market charlatans are going to pop
up to provide
services to those in need which will
cause its own
large host of problems so it's going to
be a challenging road ahead but there
are experiments being done and people
can see some of them at the foundation
website and now is there a way this is
for new zealanders is there a way that
we can access psychedelic therapy micro
dosing now or how far certainly not now
you know
ketamine is potentially available
through um there are a couple of clinics
around the country offering kidney
services for those with depression but
psychedelics and microdosing are still
micro dosing particularly has got a long
way to go there's going to be two to
five years probably it's on a three to
five year track to to progress that
depending on how the results look but i
think the first thing that's going to
come down the pipeline if anything will
be the mdma assisted therapy because
that's the most advanced psychotherapy
for ptsd so it's the most advanced
that's in phase three clinical trials in
the us we have a group of maps trained
therapists actually in new zealand that
could actually deliver that therapy if
the data was seen to be okay and our
regulator were to improve it which would
invariably happen after fda if that were
to be approved there um so we have that
and that might be only a couple years
away that would be the first kind of cab
off the rank i think
yeah and i'll just add to that that if i
could make an unrealistic request of
these psychedelic communities
per se although with the amount of
infighting that goes on it's sometimes
hard to view it that way
that
it's really important to focus on
ketamine and mdma and getting those two
right
and i think it's very
risky it's fraught with incredible risk
to try to boil the ocean at once with
adding in
nndmt 5mu dmt ayahuasca and every other
compound you can imagine to try to get
them all dealt with
in a responsible way simultaneously now
i don't think anyone's actually going to
follow that advice
but you know i have a pretty broad
spectrum of interaction with these
things and i would just say
not as an expert by any stretch but just
someone looking at the risk benefit
profiles of these things
i think a focus on ketamine and mdma
assisted psychotherapy would go a very
very long way and psilocybin certainly
is in the works and i think it has
tremendous potential for a number of
different
conditions whether that be
major depressive disorder treatment
resistant depression alcohol use
disorder and i think many others i mean
those are the three that are kind of
furthest along
but
each of these compounds has its own
complexities and difficulties and
i think
slow is smooth and smooth as fast with
this stuff we've just come through half
a century of prohibition
we don't need to figure it all out in
the next six months yeah i totally agree
with that and you know why because
there's this massive unmet need right to
get things out to address these things
and it's heartbreaking and pressing
problem but at the same time you have to
think well if these things really are
effective the last thing you want to do
is like rush it and get it wrong and
then to be safety issues that come up or
like badly regulated things and then all
these horror stories start emerging into
the popular consciousness and then we
put ourselves 50 years back in the hold
again so i think that's what we really
need to avoid with this so treating
really carefully but hopefully that
won't happen because we do have a
stronger regulatory environment than it
was in the 1960s so
hopefully we can avoid that kind of
issue but i think it requires us to work
diligently honestly and carefully
i mean not to paint a bleak picture but
it's like hey we i think we really want
to mitigate
the risk
of
catastrophe that then becomes a
political soapbox
and then before you know it you have an
executive order that sends us back to
where we were which is not an
impossibility people might laugh
about that because they feel like this
isn't the 60s and the generational
differences no longer exist
and there's bipartisan support etc but
politicians
have certain sets of incentives and
i would
really say that it is a non-zero percent
chance that things get sent back to
prohibition if say one senator's child
dies of
cavalier administration of 5meo
in
fill in the blank location right not to
throw five and mayo dmt under the bus i
think it's very interesting but
high degree of thrashing high percentage
of thrashing within the subset of people
who use it so you know bad things can
happen and bad things will happen also
and i think the
the people involved which is why the
decision foundation is also involved
with the harvard poplar project which is
a law and policy
project focused on psychedelics because
there are going to be suicides that are
attributed to psychedelics there are
going to be deaths attributed to
psychedelics via accidents of various
types and this is this would be true
with any drug
used at scale
it's not specific to psychedelics this
is certainly true for ssris it's true
for just about every drug you can
imagine sleep medications
so it's just the law of big numbers in a
sense and
i do think the community needs to be
prepared for
that eventuality and how to deal with it
because it's going to take the culture
quite a bit to metabolize that
and i do think we're going to see
a
not backlash but sort of a pendulum
swing into negative coverage because the
positive coverage is just last too long
and i think if we want to be strategic
about it we accept and expect that on
some level because inevitable with with
anything that is purported to have this
much promise and certainly anything that
has as much coverage
michelle what else do we have
is your research expanding a little bit
further and going into addiction which
is more dangerous and obviously deadly
than depression and anxiety are you
doing any research in that area
we're starting to talk about it we're
starting to talk about a project
that will be
a more maori based intervention that
will be run by maori researchers and
we're just in the very beginning stages
of starting to
sketch some ideas together about how
that might be done for that population
and methamphetamine use or alcohol use
but it's very early stages for us but
definitely that's something we're not
leading that we're just providing
support for in terms of intellectual
support and learning how to navigate the
regulatory system on this stuff so that
could be really interesting and there
are elements of for example spirituality
that have some synergy with maori
culture that
would be interesting for those
researchers to explore
so just on that a little bit then what
about have you included women in studies
or being mostly males
we had this one
lsd microdosing study where was where
was males only because we um
i won't say it was pitched warfare
trying to get this trial approved but it
was
and so we just had to like take risks
down as much as we could in certain
places so the idea of the problem of
potential pregnancy was something that
we just for this stage we just wanted to
avoid that as an issue and there was
also menstrual cycle compounds in that
that we wanted to avoid for the first
trial we think we've now got steps that
we need to expand in the future trials
but
and i've taken a lot of flack for this
and and i'll say well my response is
well you try and like get this study
approved because i spent years ago
trying to get this thing approved
so you know we did the best that we can
while we could and we always hope to do
better but certainly um all our other
studies have included females and the
next day as well
now that we've got over that first
hurdle
i will also say that there are studies
that have
very mixed
gender ratios if you look at some of the
end of life
depression end of life anxiety studies
say involving psilocybin you see a much
more sort of heterogeneous group so
definitely
easier to do when you have a little bit
of escape velocity after the first one
or two pilots
yeah there's actually some interesting
anecdotal reports of in terms of
microdosing for um premenstrual
dysphoric disorder people have been
using it for that and
that it might affect actual menstrual
cycles and mitral cycle timing so that's
actually quite an interesting there's
potentially interesting separate studies
to be done there that we have considered
and will consider in the future
so if um someone's wanting to sort of
get into this type of research what
education do you recommend for anyone
wanting to help assist
oh so i get this all the time
undergraduate student side well i'd say
you know the best option is just go be a
medical doctor
because then you can uh you learn but uh
a university degree i think i'm just
promoting the university walking because
it's my employer who pays the bills but
uh you know for young people getting us
a science degree or a health sciences
degree um medicine psychologies those
are i think
that's where the forefront of things
will will be and we'll be in either
in new zealand it's going to be
basically psychiatrists and
psychologists that are going to run this
i suspect that that will be where things
fall so if you wanted to
get into being able to prescribe or be
involved in this kind of therapy i think
psychology and psychiatry and general
medicine are the places to study so all
the things to do and then there's also
scientific degrees you can do like
medical sciences
strong background in mathematics is
always good and just going to go into
one of our corporates so have you looked
into the clinical trials of the larger
public company so this mind me compass
atai and numerous and do you feel there
any red flags and how these uh current
corporations are going about
improving their respective drugs so
that's like lsd mdma
yes and i should say as a disclosure
that i have consult for some
of these companies as a disclosure so
i'm actually collaborating with one of
them so
my observations is that
the people that these companies are
employing are really seem to be really
experienced
pharmaceutical people who have a lot of
industry experience in pharmaceuticals
and they seem to do quite a rigorous job
you know there's obviously going to be
tensions there for those companies in
terms of wanting to get things through
reasonably speedily because they've only
got so much capital you know and the
pathway is long and expensive and the
intellectual property that they need to
gain because of you know these are
generic medicines is is going to be an
issue but there's red flags within every
year is pharmaceutical development are
there any more red flags in this area
than there are in other parts of the
pharmaceutical industry probably no more
no less you know
i'm comfortable with the gray
i'll hop in with just a few things so i
would say on the on the clinical
actual the study side i think
pre-registration is very important but
as you mentioned scratch that doesn't
apply uniquely here but it does apply
here so pre-registration
publishing your protocol ahead of time
so that you can't sort of torture the
the data or or move the goal posts and
you know declare victory when in fact
it was not a victory i think is is
incredibly important and then you know i
recommend people take a look at there's
a journalist named shayla love who's
done a fair amount of writing
about the
intellectual property battles that are
ongoing in the space
and there certainly are
i believe
non-obvious
innovations that should be granted
patents because that is how
one in a market-based economy
sort of raises funds and builds
companies and justifies the r d expense
there are also
obvious
relatively unhelpful non-improvements
that people sometimes get patents for
which are obstructionist in nature
and
that actually gum up the works and cause
problems in the ecosystem overall
especially if they use said patents to
try to
lock up manufacturing processes to
dominate a given molecule that has
existed for
decades if not
millennia in some cases so i do think
the ip side of things is very important
to to keep an eye on and an organization
that might be worth checking out is
freedom to operate which was created by
carrie turnbull
and that is an area that will be
increasingly
active
mason marks and
i glenn cohen i period glenn coenceo
h-e-n co-authored a paper on
intellectual property and patents for
those who are interested that's out of
harvard law school
it's enough time for our questions
actually team goes fast
all right well well fantastic thank you
so much everybody and thank you uh so
much suresh for for making the time i'm
very excited to see what you do next
cool thank you
good thanks team i'll just close this
off for a cutting
it's been a great session today and then
hopefully this will set you on the rest
of your way
kierto
or papa nuku
on
enjoy the rest of your evening all day
[Music]
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week kind of like my diary of
cool things it often includes articles
i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim dot blog slash friday type that into
your browser tim dot blog slash friday
drop in your email and you'll get the
very next one thanks for listening
[Applause]
you